we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p really
important issue brought up in this
voicemail about the importance of every
vote take a listen
my name is joshua phone chicago illinois
my friend
voted and 2016 for hillary clinton yes
and ever since then what the result came
back Donald Trump actually won I guess
he's on the opinion that she just
believed that both doesn't matter pretty
much right and I was just wondering if
there was a way maybe you could order
something you could say to convince her
otherwise of me personally I do believe
that both matter and I certainly believe
that Barack Obama's proof of that
because it both didn't matter then
because a lot of people said that brocco
bomb was never going to get in yeah
and here's the deal there were a lot of
people who had the same thought as as
your friend and didn't even vote in 2016
there are millions of people in 2016 who
said you know I don't really think my
vote matters even though I don't want
Trump I'm not gonna bother and go out
and vote and if those millions of people
just had gone out and voted for Hillary
Clinton we would not have president
Trump right now we would not have the
disaster that is facing the Kurds in
northern Syria right now we would not
have one of the most radical right
judiciary's at both the Supreme Court
and lower court levels that we've had in
decades thanks to Donald Trump so if
anything the 2016 election it should not
dissuade people from voting it should be
confirmation that if only a few of those
people who said I'm not gonna bother to
vote which is half the country how
embarrassing is that half the country
doesn't vote if even just a fraction of
those people had gone out and voted we
never would have had president Trump to
begin with so your friend is right to be
frustrated but the conclusion to draw is
not doesn't even make sense to vote the
conclusion to draw is if all of us
were skeptical about our ability to make
change by voting just went out and cast
the damn ballot we would have easily
defeated Donald Trump in 2016 and we
could easily defeat Donald Trump in 2020
that's the that's the conclusion that we
should all be coming to no matter what
state you're in no matter how safe you
think your congressional district is for
your member of Congress if you like them
or whatever else go out and vote if
everybody who questioned the importance
of voting went out and voted they
wouldn't stand a chance we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about Bernie's plan to give workers
an ownership stake in big companies we
will talk about a record-setting sub two
hour marathon incredible incredible and
we will talk about what's going on with
the NBA and China and Hong Kong a lot to
discuss there all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show sign up at
join pakman.com 148 new members over the
weekend taking advantage of the big
membership drive coupon code if you're
interested in taking advantage of that
I'm glad to extend it to you for another
day or two
get in touch through our website contact
form ask me for the code I'll send it to
you and it'll be a beautiful thing if we
can get maybe closer to 200 people
taking advantage of that code talk to
you in just a few moments on the bonus
show